اعلن المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
دانييل هاجار اتمام الكشف عن الانفاق التي
تستخدمها حركه حماس في شمال غزه وفق
تعبيره واضاف ان العمليه البريه ستتواصل
وبان الغارات الجويه الاسرائيليه مستمره
على
القطع اتممنا الكشف عن الانفاق التي
تستخدمها حركه حماس في شمال غزه وسنقضي
على كل البنى في تلك المناطق الاستراتيجيه
وسنواصل العمليه ايضا في جنوب غزه لكي نصل
الى المرافق الموجوده تحت الارض والتي
تستخدمها حماس في منطقه خانيونس وفي
الايام الاخيره قمنا باضافه كتيبه اخرى
الى الكتائب الهندسيه من اجل البحث عن
الانفاق والقضاء
عليها ونشر الناطق باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
صورا لما قال انه استكمال عمليه السيطره
على مركز قياده حماس في قطاع غزه وقال
الجيش الاسرائيلي ان قواته استكملت
السيطره على ما سماه مربع المسؤولين في
وسط مدينه غزه المربع بحسب الجيش
الاسرائيلي يشمل شبكه انفاق متشعبه تربط
بين ما وصفها بشقق الاختباء والدواوين
والمكاتب والشقق التي كان يسكنها مسؤول
الجناح العسكري والمكتب السياسي لحماس
واضاف الجيش الاسرائيلي ان هذه العمليات
جرت في حي الرمال وميدان فلسطين حيث
اكتشفت هذه الانفاق التي يدعي جيش
الاحتلال ان مسؤولين في حماس استخدموها
منهم اسماعيل هانيه ويحيى السنوار ومحمد
الضيف